We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P really important issue.
Brought up in this voicemail about the importance
of every vote.
Take a listen
David, my name is Joshua phone in Chicago,
Illinois.
My friend voted in 2016 for Hillary thin.
Yes.
And ever since then, once it was all came
back, the Trump actually won.
I guess she's on the opinion that she just
believes that votes doesn't matter pretty
much.
Right.
And I was just wondering if there was a way
to maybe do, or there's something you could
say to convince her otherwise.
Cause me personally, I do believe that both
matter and I personally believe I'll type
of off Obama's proof of that because it both
didn't matter then because a lot of people
said that Barack Obama was never going to
get in.
Yeah.
Here's the deal.
Uh, there were a lot of people who had the
same thought as a, as your friend and didn't
even vote in 2016 there are millions of people
in 2016 who said, you know, I don't really
think my vote matters even though I don't
want Trump.
I'm not going to bother and go out and vote.
And if those millions of people just had gone
out and voted for Hillary Clinton, we would
not have president Trump right now.
We would not have the disaster that is facing
the Kurds in Northern Syria right now.
We would not have one of the most radical
right judiciaries at both the Supreme court
and lower court levels that we've had in decades
thanks to Donald Trump.
So if anything, the 2016 election, it should
not dissuade people from voting.
It should be confirmation that if only a few
of those people who said, I'm not going to
bother to vote, which is half the country.
How embarrassing is that?
Half the country doesn't vote.
If even just a fraction of those people had
gone out and voted, we never would have had
president Trump to begin with.
So your friend is right to be frustrated,
but the conclusion to draw is not, doesn't
even make sense to vote.
The conclusion to draw is if all of us who
are skeptical about our ability to make change
by voting just went out and cast the damn
ballot, we would have easily defeated Donald
Trump in 2016 and we could easily defeat Donald
Trump in 2020 that's the, that's the conclusion
that we should all be coming to.
No matter what state you're in, no matter
how safe you think your congressional district
is for your member of Congress, if you like
them or whatever else, go out and vote.
If everybody who questioned the importance
of voting went out and voted, they wouldn't
stand a chance.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Bernie's plan to give workers
an ownership stake in big companies.
We will talk about a record setting, sub two
hour marathon.
Incredible, incredible, and we will talk about
what's going on with the NBA and China and
Hong Kong.
A lot to discuss there.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, sign up@joinpacman.com 148 new members
over the weekend.
Taking advantage of the big membership drive
coupon code.
If you're interested in taking advantage of
that, I'm glad to extend it to you for another
day or two.
Get in touch through our website contact form.
Ask me for the code,
I'll send it to you and it'll be a beautiful
thing.
If we can get a maybe closer to 200 people
taking advantage of that code, I'll talk to
you in just a few moments on the bonus.
Check the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].